so what if this is all true right I was
out of the conference in cal
ago and on the wall street journal does
it every year it's called economics so
George Shultz was up there speaking okay
so you know the Secretary of everything
yes but it was labor he was state and
defense I think it was defense anyway
he's got to be in his 90s still sharpers
attack but he brought up an interesting
example he went back to the Reagan days
it was about CFCs okay we thought the
ozone member the ozone layer that whole
thing some of you guys remember it some
others you don't so there was a lot of
science that said the ozone layer is
going to be gone we're all going to be
cooked we're all going to get skin
cancer crop failure blah blah blah lots
of science on both sides and so Schultz
describe this conversation that they had
and Reagan was sitting there listening
to his side of the aisle a bunch of guys
saying it's BS the science isn't there
we're not doing it he said you know what
it is that it is their slightest
possibility that it might be true Kemp
can we can see that it might be true and
so grudgingly you know some of the heads
and he said well why don't we just buy
an insurance policy why wouldn't we buy
an insurance policy if it could happen
what I thought about was compelling
about that is many times we have these
discussions particular when you open
these discussions up to the broader
public we talk about carbon capture a
sequestration cap-and-trade nobody gets
it only experts get it and then then
maybe maybe they get it but when you
talk about an insurance policy doesn't
everybody get that mean do we all buy
insurance yep to do what to protect
ourselves and our kids for what for the
obvious that's going to happen is my
house going to burn down oh my god it
you know am I going to die of a heart
attack tomorrow maybe not but I might I
just I thought it was a compelling idea
the idea of insurance and that you know
as we as we also try to take whatever
policies to the people because it's so
politicized some simple thoughts like
that we're talking about insurance here
you know if you had to tell everybody in
the US that they had to pay 500 bucks a
year to potentially protect their
and children from the type of calamities
we're talking about they might say okay
I get it it's insurance